you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it would help if I had my mic Robert so
it turns out I lied to everybody that
was on watching the stream earlier when
me and Nick we're playing Madden I said
that we weren't gonna play call of duty
till tomorrow
well that's holy lying I think we're
still gonna play call of duty world up
world war two I thought all that war I
know it's not what Sid Biden World War
two because it is out live early for
some reason see as you can see I'm not
lying to you
nope I don't know they just decided to
drop it it was supposed to be 10:00 a.m.
tomorrow tomorrow but it's out and about
so here we are we can even check out
that new war mode which is the one you
like the most right yeah I think we
should jump into that just because it's
I think the most interesting the rest is
just you know it's caught it feels a Cod
which is we can so show that later
that's not a bad thing let's do it let's
go to wall so this is the private beta
if you had pre-ordered on ps4 will play
on ps4 you should have had access to it
so you can download that now if you
didn't know that or apparently if you
contact Comcast if you have it you can
get a code you call Comcast customer
service apparently they are giving our
codes
assuming wait sorry on the caveat that
you are a Comcast like have a Comcast
member sure it's not just like you call
them and like oh by the way right
currently ps4 only I believe cultivates
I'm pretty sure because they have the
exclusive now right for like that month
time to exclusive kind of sure so yes I
believe ps4 only I hope but yeah game I
hope so we were just playing
Oh both you and I were on the mgs yup
tearing up fools and then we were
getting rekt right like we were so warm
mode for those that don't know what it
is why don't you tell us what what like
how it works
war mode is a series of objectives with
an attacking and defending teams so we
were the defending team it starts with
like your first objective which is like
defend the house you can set up
barricades very almost similar to like
kind of like nazi zombies or you're like
yeah in a wrench and putting up barriers
you're
repairing machine-gun turrets your your
you're even getting like air drops of
like a flamethrower in order to defend
yourself against the Allies who are
attacking in this specific map and there
yeah there's a series of objectives so
if we lose that first house it moves on
to a different objective where the
Allies have to build a bridge to cross
ideally to like bring their tank and
then the next one is like blow up an
ammo dump and then the final one is for
the Allies to have their Sherman tank
get through and destroy the axis
artillery barrage yeah so basically you
have these little like I don't want to
call them checkpoints but little points
of interest yeah that you know one team
has to defend one team has to attack and
eventually got to get through those
points in different stages of the level
what yeah what I and what I like about
it is that like the first one it's just
a house
so you're you're inclined to use you
know close range weapons and then at the
bridge you know you're kind of doing a
little more sniping but it's very clear
as far as like the front line and the
spawn points of each side so I just I
know it's it's simple and it's easy you
know I feel like it's more relaxing than
this one so here you go we have
divisions as well if you guys can hear
with those in each division you start
with this kind of specific gun it
doesn't mean that you're tied to it but
right you have kind of like perks in a
way for each division that way like I
have five ranks each that you level up
there's like two series of different
types of progression trees that you can
you can try will move the camera box
since it's bothering you guys I'm moving
to the top
I'll do that while Rob's playing and
kind of talking oh that's oh god what's
your clothes
dolphin dad so this is the first point
of interest right the house that you're
making
yeah we're Germans we're Germans trying
to hold it down they're advancing and
not like and they have to kind of like
it's almost like domination right like
you have to hold the point for so long
right bomb one of them right sorry I'm
gonna fix the PIP thanks for warning me
they're gonna move it to the top right
because that seems to be a decent safe
spot to put it yeah don't let them over
on that command post Oh sick grenade
throw did you nail it yeah I nailed it
on yourself
yeah all right how's that guys hopefully
that works out better you can download
it like I said if you pre-ordered it on
ps4 but if you didn't then unfortunately
you can't play unless you were able to
get a key with someone else if you are a
Comcast customer you should be able to
call their customer service and get a
key that way is what I've heard so there
you go Chris hopefully that helps you so
this is kind of what your you're
mentioning you kind of build up turret
I'm gonna call it a serve even though
it's like mg
oMG nests kill and they are powerful
yeah that's gonna be a hurtful but you
know where these are as the as the
opposition so you try to Nate them where
a long range try to go around that guy
didn't see obviously it is day one
essentially I guess sends anyone that's
plated at Gamescom or something like
that or early you didn't get to see it
last week right Rob yeah I did I based
about to see exactly what you're seeing
here for the most part the the trees
seem to be seems like your your so you
get upgrade tokens which you can then
use on other perks and stuff Oh wrong
gun you get tokens which you can then
use on on weapon upgrades attachments
and another series of perks you so you
have your division perks and you also
have your you also have oh oh so we lost
you lost your first point we got to back
up to our next kind of point that we're
defending which is the yellow line kind
of indicates hey you have this bridge
that they have to build right running
that's always tough to like fall back
like that like real war man you're
supposed to be running like the Russian
guys woulda shot you if you were running
back sure sure enemy at the gate style
Vassili Zaitsev sure sorry there guy not
even the same but alright so you got a
flamethrower which is a drop
it's a weird it mean you get it
consistently throughout these objectives
but here's a weird kind of area to do it
just because like this is like the most
open area of oh you kind of hold down
that all right that's true because it
was hard to use so they're they're down
there like like prone trying to oh I
just block them up I love it
hello to zenkei hello Bale Ishmael
it hasn't been reviewed yet destroy a
server we're just playing the private
beta
what's up goob welcome back welcome to
all you guys thank you guys for tuning
in ya know they're just an impromptu
stream but we did not think that the
call of duty
yeah called du-de du-de du-de private
beta was gonna be available till
tomorrow but they dropped it early so
here we are playing it for you guys and
we'll Rob seen some of this so he'll try
to answer your questions to the best of
his ability and I'll try to relay that
to him but obviously he is playing so of
course it's gonna be a little difficult
he is mopping it up here at the MGM s oh
I didn't see the window for yellow yeah
he figured it out was a good run well he
had to somebody so that's part of the
the what the enemy would have to do
there to is switch to sniping there to
kind of get you off those mg off the mg
ness
totally otherwise you're pretty much
just hosing them down right like yeah oh
that's nice still there
oh there's two snipers on their team now
now why'd you do it oh [ __ ] oh I lost my
breath enemies building the bridge man
what shot one cute shooter so we should
probably oh no that was a landline
acclaim where if you will
oh yes I like it
just do it oh he's trying to build it
what an idiot you don't build when
there's a sniper on the enemy team
actually no you're supposed to because
otherwise they're never gonna get across
the bridge now is this a tow it is a
time kind of thing right yeah and I
think it just ends oh so sorry come
again later
yeah exactly
oh this guy oh they get coal at it oh no
dude everyone I'm Jim the coal that's
when you get the two head two kills in
one bullet collateral
nice when is beta coming out dedicated
out private beta right now if you
pre-ordered on ps4 these guys are just
game worked I feel bad for them oh you
got out you got hitmarker come on blind
finally it's quick so so smoke is super
key here yeah yeah that's what the other
team was doing to us last last map
they're just spamming the smoke and yeah
repairing about to get it done right now
over here comes Rob all listen oh so now
we're out great good that mine it yeah
lame I sure think you're just gonna get
shot this next area it might be good for
the flamethrowers oh right yeah I still
have a cost yeah
ooh artillery strike there though or
something took out three of their guys
there wow I almost done
yep Brandon O'Neill's correct they said
it was supposed to start tomorrow 10:00
a.m. Pacific time but it just dropped it
early today so yeah we are streaming in
1080 and you go thanks for noticing that
nope
that guy got killed by someone else um
so you can build barriers around this
thing right it from what I could tell
yeah we probably should be but let's see
this Oh tank Oh didn't mean to do that
is correct swish Pro noob if you are a
Comcast customer you can call their
customer hotline and get a beta key that
way as well so how are you liking the
kind of return to World War you know -
yeah well this creature what I find it
refreshing its it still feels it like
cod you know okay let's try this out oh
you're dead
so the good thing about the flamethrower
when you pick it up is I still have it
it just it just has like a certain time
oh yeah that's good that's fair yeah I
think it's fair - because you diet a lot
in god burger
yeah and I mean this is a specific mode
so it kind of and they're they're very
spot flames up flame on oh why would you
close it yeah right we're about to go
hey I'll have a barbecue and start a
barbecue out of you all right that's it
burn yourself no I know no I did not I
got antsy so it's interesting charlie
there was for me there's a lot of iron
sights at first but then there is that
kind of like hollow sight which is good
yeah you get different variations of it
all right going flame throwing hot baby
oh I still have it thank you oh yeah
how's the rainbow it's generous not that
generous oh it's I mean for a flame
thrower I feel like maybe it could be a
little further further
Ricky once you lose it it's gone you
just moved back to another objective
point essentially and you try to hold
that one and so now oh not the sniper I
thought you're gonna get that one shot
again oh this guy's got the right idea
oh that I was looking at chat he sent up
the church back there he's far back
that's smart though you want to have
those ready so that once they come
you're pretty much ready yeah
nice nice a gesture this is the weird
thing for me like [ __ ] watching that
you're gonna see hopefully this can kind
of go back and forth don't land ride
it's like or why would it ever go
backwards like that it's just kind of
awkward oh yeah but me and you were just
like sitting going up you're on the one
to the right I was here yeah you have to
watch out for like that one little
window right and they're like ahead of
you yeah as long as there's another guy
in that other turret there's actually a
third turret I think yeah you're seeing
you can see him on the mini-map
like I need an advance Jimmy ETL in
terms of the other multiplayer maps
summers not that big actually it's a lot
of more close quarters I felt like I was
at least in TDM I was having a lot of
SMG battles it felt like sure I didn't
have an SMG I felt like that a
disadvantage maybe an AR was fine too
that's why I enjoyed this mode or this
mode the most oh [ __ ] because it is more
open watch it's going backwards it's
just it's just gonna go backwards right
now there's no one there like ah we
better back up guys sorry it's scared I
wish I could do something this is such a
bottleneck sauce alright you're just
waiting for the new comic right there
well you said the flamethrower too by
the way barely honey it will run here a
little toasty Robin oh yeah oh yeah
finish him a little bit sure his
eyebrows eyebrows yeah my dad is in the
photo nah
here we go it's on the move yup see all
I gotta do is watch out for that foot
see what are your teammates should you
legit be on that other one right cuz
always Sookie he gets all the vision of
them coming down this way this
chokepoint right right your opinion when
I watch a left yeah you're watching to
make sure they're gonna hop over and
then cleaning up some of these guys it's
a pretty tough spot to break here we go
what I could tell but maybe you just
they weren't sniping I don't know
yeah well unfortunately uh this dropped
out for us when we were that's right
yeah that sucks for him it's like what's
he ever gonna do about that right yeah
good point
like I would imagine he can't see past
that wall see I go and I've definitely
been in that seat before anything you
can't you can't say oh we've got back it
up these do I will say these do overheat
so you can't just like hold it down
right and for them they just have to be
near the tank right to push it or be in
the paint right so you like if you're if
you're attacking in the tank you'd want
to be behind it you know it's like it's
like payload right for ready - yup - or
overwatch right call of overwatch says
Chris cynic - well this parts a little
over watching so now they're throwing a
grenades because I know what's up yeah
but they're not getting it far enough
no Oh watch out line em up baby yeah
thank you we'll take a little two-piece
to be special back it up
get yo ass back there Oh
far enough so right now there's we
throwing smoke yeah they only have 30
seconds they're just trying to lob the
grenades right now don't hold down feet
long
oh that guy creamed it up whoo that was
a close range just gonna hurt this we
all good we're near some sandbags cindex
I was he on it yep
yeah it's a tough spot for you but if
there's one on the other guy one wish
you have right now you're really tough
for them oh here we go here's a little
quick by them and your teammates are
doing the right thing right one guy on
the other one other guys pushing up so
that guy there you know that they can't
really advance a tank safely like I
don't this is a tough spot to break
absolutely when I played at the preview
event last week did they ever get past
we just we just switched sides once and
yeah it always ended there we were never
like when I went as the Allies for the
second run we crushed and we would like
got way way through all those objectives
until that last one that bottleneck and
that you just can't
so does this saw it become a thing where
once you switch sides is it who does it
faster if you guys tiebreak there or
does it just end up in a time what do
you mean by that
so okay you stopped them there right
yeah now it's your turn to try to exact
right yeah so pathetically if you were
to tie right like is it just based off
of who does it faster or do you just tie
at the end of it because you guys both
got the same bet that's a really good
question actually I don't know all right
we'll find out that find out about to
find out so we got a captured the
command post pushing me out of the way
yeah there is some collision I noticed
this yeah right when I was running I
kind of like was like I'm scooted it to
the side bites by like you know my
teammate going silencer here sneaking
sneaking our way in dead body
alright Rob's going the long way I like
it
cooking a grenade
that's a stun grenade do not get anyone
but where do you sit here you just sit
here now yeah taking it nice I think
you're good too you got guys where are
these guys this is weird
they don't know where to go
is this it this is 66 that correct okay
or close five b-52 guys a short a couple
people oh hello boys rainbow succeed
yeah pretty much
so now it's steve-o steve-o 8 1 3 7 2 I
don't think we can say Cod's dead yet
everything you'd be shocked by how many
people enjoy playing Cod and by Cod like
every year so yeah no no like I brat and
I'd rather have this kind of callback
[Music]
yeah you need to kind of snipe this spot
right yeah yeah well hopefully you got
some guys building the bridge go see him
do you have so which class does the
smokies that would be airborne
so probably needs some airborne guys so
you can mix and match right like the the
divisions are I'd be so cool how you
just do that I think it does go through
the wall but I don't think you'll kill
him in like one shot out of that barn so
I got window so we really gotta take
this guy out oh yes and he flinched back
rob was scared that he wasn't gonna hit
that shot alright good see so one of
your teammates throwing smoke
oh he just ate a grenade though
what are you doing you crazy you're not
even scoping til I got it right now
clear that other that other nest is
what's going busy on there again it
Excel
he was only got a shot on okay sometimes
tough that that's tough oh my some
waiting just waiting for you defeat I
was dumb dude oh good damn you guys are
not building you guys need to get some
building some people got to get prone oh
my god I do everything myself
just gotta get thrown got start slamming
the ranch there you go that sniper oh my
god Oh which I another another not a
[ __ ] I lost a leg on that one yeah we
need some we need some hot smoke we got
a we got 54% of this bridge to build I
mean that's the things I should be oh
here we go definitely guy other guy once
all I saw the guy there is apparently bf
ones a new CTE map is out today that's
pretty awesome
let's support here oh I don't have I
don't have smoke a here's one of the
standard loadouts have it yeah that
airborne that's fine you got you guys
got a minute so you got to get on that
gotta start like I said get to build him
personally I know but if you smoke it
you should be able to get some building
down
no smoke no is this good am i building
you know you're not you gotta be up
there
smoke it try to smoke it what do you got
to be closer he's got a foul is it
really this close that is and he's
knifing so yeah you gotta lay down that
smoke all right I think you guys are
about to lose this though real talk
it's not looking good for the offense
here oh yeah that smoke down go go go go
go oh my god this hit range ah looks
like it's a GG unless you guys can just
get there but these guys are just
getting Yolo here is guys geo lowing oh
yeah yeah yeah hold it baby
oh okay no you guys got something near
the barrel
he's got no sight oh oh so it is a push
and pull so we fall back okay no you got
the bridge oh why didn't they fall back
I think was them that you want
spectating the ocean good fall Thank You
fan what's the best thing about new Cod
asking named McNamee Rob uh this mode
for one thing but I like I like toning
it back and just like having more stuff
like simplistic look them on just
weapons and weapon types and I don't
know kind of
like there's like a there's like a
playing field that gets kind of pulled
that or like spread out I what I would
say what I mean like I don't know like I
always built Ozio I'm inside so I can't
do [ __ ] now yeah you can't move up
anymore until they've been planted I
guess that how it goes I know our
objective right now is to blow up blow
down right there get in there
no tell me like I'm offering a little
support a job good support huh nope not
today sir oh hello oh okay he's got a
mine there so you might want oh that
almost I already died throwing it I
guess oh yes very good maybe you can
flank my pants oh I can't go any further
there oh really
yeah okay you guys are you guys are
trying to get the thing a Hello crazy
sniper guy oh not today fine you can you
can show this corner like that one guy
did to you
well we actually have to hold square on
that thing kid we did we set it we did
it
there's their cargo hold they don't know
they don't know Rob Rob on a hot streak
he was till I know I wanted some I wanna
put silence right yeah we're gonna tell
you that to you I didn't wanna backseat
gaming a lot whoa do I go now huh do you
need any invite to play you needed to
pre-order the game or apparently if
you're Comcast like Xfinity I don't know
if it's a 1080 but if you're a Comcast
customer you can get in by calling their
customer service apparently or they'll
give you a key that is the weirdest
thing have you ever done anything like
that I don't know but it's a new thing
you know Comcast sorry one-way gamer
that you can't play but I'm glad you're
here tuning it in oh wow that was good
let's see it got that guy and he's like
oh there's a guy in the tank oh you are
now shot he's young young kid reflexes
Rob yeah wanna Tom Hanks just like as
you're dying
Ernie he was so cool when he actually
liked it I was like wow did he yeah they
had to go bullet that he feathered it I
was like no no no p-51 Oh
yep okay all right
escort the other tank Oh flamethrower is
going to town oh my god what an idiot
okay you got it got you got a tank
gunner
alright here's here's a tough part how
do we beat this you know you know
they're waiting oh this is me yeah the
worst gun right now is here right you
should Pisces which after I like go you
know this we have held this point
together you know how tough is this oh
maybe if you can get through maybe if
this guy stop blocking my little oh you
know I'll do smoke it Oh contact it
meant for it wait for it oh wow that's
him you know what maybe they didn't
build the turrets damn geez maybe then
you build up idiots idiots turrets wow I
haven't seen this animation
see ya artillery happy Valentine's Day
Nazis good work ten kills one defend one
demolition no builds one of the guns
that was that on that was when I was a
German I think oh okay makes sense
oh that's fine it can crash now that's
fine hello hello hello game was off her
game go full camera right now hey guys
that's us we just Oh what's this is that
new thing that you can you can do that
right at the end screen okay nice ring
nothing in little know what McNish in
fifth grade who you got unlike you got
that so that's the third SMG the type
100 I want to see it I want to use it
okay let's see here I can unlock another
division Kevin Rosalie the private beta
is out right now if you pre-ordered it
or as I mentioned if you're a Comcast
member apparently so you can download it
I think it's about 1213 gigs on ps4
plate right now
thanks for tuning in and checking us out
while we play we're fighting to play
again tomorrow morning
yes that's what was slated and Rob will
probably have more unlocks by then
probably it's my guess yeah so I should
get this sure you said you wanted it
yeah guys the modest damage and
something about range I haven't tried it
out yet then you got to get some hot
reloaded so right now I have oh I want
this no King Davy oh she went to three I
don't believe you can play zombies in
beta currently can you right it's this
multiplayer there's a TDM domination war
mode two attachments interesting I
wanted some of the things you unlock
right yeah so this is like another way
you can like level up and put your / you
where the perks have separated is to
basic training bad
so to speak so you can like see some of
them here that you're familiar with you
don't need your secondary weapon now
just pick one he'll know exactly let's
go war mode again
well we've kind of seen that you want to
move around we can do whatever you
wanted I think the two easiest is
probably war mortar team deathmatch in
terms of like people domination might be
okay to be I'm not sure let's give this
a shot and get rekt the you'll see that
the TDM maps are a little bit smaller
more close quarters yeah a lot more
action-packed obviously a lot cod yeah
and I find myself like seeing the same
lanes over and over again you know what
I mean like you're kind of three lanes
yeah you're kind of doing the same there
is a little bit of verticality I'm at
least that one map where there's like
the the satellite kind of like bunker
area so and then there's like the house
that on the left with the trenches yeah
yeah there are so there are lanes but
there's so some verticality there yeah
yeah so now we're gonna check out some
TDM we'll see how Rob does and yeah it's
a social space in there
no no it's not it's not they kind of
show it to you in the beginning like
right when you get in kind of you know
what I mean yeah that was like a weird
intro there is a trailer you can check
it out there's some shots of it you know
you have like I'd imagine like a gun
range you can compete with people the
the one the one that stands out to me
okay try again
the one that stands out to me is like
the king of the hill type of like pit
we're like you can watch someone play
and why don't one right one on one and
then ideally like you know next person
up survive as long as you can in the pit
against like more and more people who
come in I think I think that the social
pits are 48 people oh wow
yeah it's pretty phat cool so you see
like there it's like the total like kind
of destiny like third-person like
perspective so everyone's just like
doing emotes and cheering for the for
the dudes
unfortunately angel Navarro that there's
no social space that we can show you you
just got to watch the trailer adjuster
and switch test this is a Craig
your shirt's and then King gave Yoshi
what would you guys rate this game so
far that's kind of tough but you where
only we'd only be basing in a
multiplayer alone
so that's really hard to say yeah and
also you know there's technically there
are four Maps including war but yeah I
don't know I mean there I would imagine
there are a dozen Maps right at least
all right the most
oh so this is that map we're talking
about with the trenches and the bunkers
so yeah this one's good to see it I
still think that SMG or like assault
rifle is like the way to go at least on
these maps that I've played so far and I
can show you like shotgun yeah do you
have the incendiary rounds on those
right so so the division always has so
if you pick expeditionary division your
shotguns will have these fire rounds and
I don't know shopping shotguns are good
only one on your team yeah thought so
sorry just play it through people will
connect so I could like take these out
if I wanted to oh then you load regular
ones so I start off with four V's just
four and then I move on my regular ammo
do you get four per new life yeah but I
feel like the fire rate with the
incendiary rounds or is like slower so
I'm not like it like a huge advocate of
them okay but it makes sense though I
mean like there's gotta be good be it
would be right if they gave you a slight
disadvantage we're using is he gonna die
today I don't know he's burning maybe
that's unfortunate yeah cuz it look like
you got um pretty square on there yet
you think like the range isn't that
great - in my opinion they're just used
to your o-p-s titanfall shotgun yeah
it's been nerfed
all about that shotty life that shotgun
life though alright two against four is
to your advantage you should be able to
find them or they're all following each
other and can't you know it's like this
is a hot spot yeah it's right like
that's why the day because he has a burn
out
maybe you switch to your pistol real
quick to finish him off baby yeah I
don't do that enough that's for sure you
got two more in sitting Gary's alright
Rob playing song playing it nice and
slow you saw this guy came in I know
like I get in my head on the juking you
know I mean like Oh
next level alright let's let's get get
can oh here we go real deal real deal
real deal SMG alright that's it
more dots says we can get oh watch out
it's my kill didn't surprise you didn't
see my song even push you oh oh I
thought it was him fake dead body
joke's on you fake dead body but yeah
yeah yeah let's get some kills Rob
I sure would really like to get some
killstreaks going I've gone like up to
artillery closest now I got messing
around yeah I got up to artillery what's
that last one it's artillery so it's
recon one bomb guided bomb and then it's
artillery artillery is flatten you like
weight and do it right barf
what are you why are you going into a
corner for oh nice Kingslayer
okay Wow little awkward you'd think that
was real awkward it's not a one hit
anyone it ain't all right and you got
you with this slow ass LMG he feels bad
Oh Philanthropies got your dots dude you
heard that Oh Nikki a call-out left side
right side many ropes sorry I don't get
it yeah it's a while eat it up top nice
the old get shot from the back mmm
that's the one thing that like I have to
relax on like cuz that frustrates me you
know like but it's our I mean I'm used
to it I guess let's get right someone
he's upstairs let's see what happens
ah Steve saying Ken where's that
question can you play the side-by-side
to be f1 show the massive black and
white contrast of how different they
look that would be amazing
interesting live try not live definitely
not alive nice oh yes
me likey I like the combo you guys well
yeah man single uh single shot all right
close and write it yeah the the grande
yeah so is that a is that a basic
training thing to have to yes that's one
that you want you can unlock so I went
for that with my token I thought it was
a good one too
the only the only other thing I like to
do is I like to steal a weapon and swap
my fists yeah that's that's out that's
definitely ooh he's upstairs
oh yeah that guy's got the right leg you
ain't you ain't coming through this this
spot Oh put this bar we were talking
about earlier there's the guy that was
prone his mind was set on something else
we were talking earlier the jump
animations are real stiff like it just
it looks like there's no fluid motion to
like do it jumping when you can't see it
but you'll see people like do that jump
if you like it like that he's like yeah
yeah their legs are just stick it seems
to be a legit tactic though oh for sure
I've been seeing people doing the jump
shot him yeah it's just dolphin dive ins
back yeah it is I haven't done any of
that yet so risky I've gotta get I gotta
get back to like getting used to clawing
kind of where like you can you're
shooting but you're holding down circle
at the same time to drop shot what yeah
some people do claw I just try to do it
like with my bone it's it feels awkward
but it helps because they're so fixated
on shooting you this way that was as
you're dropping down your pike kill them
it's like a legit contact they've got it
I smell some activity over here oh yeah
look at this guy
you're right oh wait Scott Turner all
right we'll keep it busy that brought
back so many bad wild memories no you
should only have good while Emily's
legit just easier this guy's crazy that
guy wasn't you know what though he felt
confident because of all the shots he
missed
yeah that's a good tactic I should but I
shouldn't miss more but you baited him
because he thought you had a pistol but
turns out you had a oh yeah you're right
I'm sorry yet a like rifle he thought
you probably only had a pistol back up
he thought I was just a long-range
hustler yep but you hustled him I did
baited him in with the long-range only
two uh yeah I worked out and you killed
someone
shut your mouth Ricky I don't want to
hear about the duel betrayer of
humanities huh
nothing don't worry about it it's a well
it's a while thing talking to chat good
topic yup oh yeah yeah
[Music]
all the sky in the window I'm sorry and
I was I was ready to be like yeah yeah
yeah the DubLi and then you like
confession
oh they got artillery yeah you got our
show someone's doing good that's you
yeah yeah you're right it's she's
hitting nobody though he's air ball in
right now you got to be real patient
with you don't just let that thing off
you got it yes study that man guys not
afraid you think he's gonna get into the
kill streak oppa memo oh my god dammit
that scene is so hard of why yeah that's
hard real hard it's pretty tough for
those that don't know Saving Private
Ryan mm-hmm
terrible scene never forget God that
scene there's a bayonet is this more
frustrating than is all the trials are
less no zealot trials are more
frustrating i I loves oldest so much oh
he's got he's got that's an ollie I
think that's a perk wait wait no that's
that's a killstreak I think no watch out
are they i they're coming in here I'm
not sure if there's an open beta white
dragon hello BSG what's up tuning in
so you do a little flank I think they're
in here funky flavor private is a great
movie you can give yo if you like a band
of brothers see why your eyes oh hell
yeah not a movie but that's on HBO if
you got Game of Thrones going that got
that subscription you can check that out
all right here we go here we go and into
the thick of it hopefully maybe Rob will
find somebody he's ran the whole map I
got a feeling they're people in here
let's get this on to it does wrong come
on after all that where are they Jimmy
where are they they're across the map
not even I see what this guy was doing
this isn't gonna go well I have a
feeling it's Church in that Dom spot is
it though you just got killed by it John
flew to fire saying this looks sick Oh
Victoria though with a little maybe semi
play of the game ish oh hell yeah watch
this oh so that is like a play of the
game then right yeah obviously this
frickin Lobby sucks we need a new one
yeah it does we need one of the more
people white dragon saying he thinks
open beta September 1st could be I could
also try looking that up for you guys
let me see let me see let me see let me
see
do check sick play the game so sick such
a sick was it how many shots were missed
I got I think I hit him once nailed it
apparently you don't even have to
pre-order if you're a Comcast person Oh
owns the Comcast account everything I
see right now is for clothes Eric look
at these emotes destiny and catch I
thought how many money you have for yet
the paper yeah I paid real money for him
oh really mm-hmm
it's like 20 bucks per they didn't I did
not that's a lie can you not spread
false information sure
so yeah this oh I so I can get this so I
got some Molotov cocktails going sure
some Molly's Molly Molly so the game
actually releases November 3rd for
scorpion fury I don't even know if I
want multiple cocktails all right too
late why not I don't know I bet you
they're pretty decent on that a war mode
oh wait you don't have you don't have
kill streaks in that one yeah okay maybe
domination sure yeah
light up those points mm-hmm mm-hmm yeah
I like that har point maybe yeah sure um
I hear we do here we go there we go
I like this alright I do like this map
I've actually of my killstreaks I've
having Adam on this map here good luck
to you then on this one if you're
getting a kill streak for the stream
right you're gonna show case you're
crazy Call of Duty skills
well now the pressures on that's one
hell of a shirt there okay it's crazy Oh
Michael okay okay
I stunned them for my buddies Eric
they're gonna come you have to be on a
squad to play multi-player know you
could you can play by yourself we're
just playing around right now obviously
it helps to have buddies that yeah suck
it put this bar come on dude give him
that jump yeah it works every time oh
god you're such a terrible spot no this
is great
just what I wanted
yeah I gotta go see you guys jeez I
can't believe that guy didn't push you
alright alright we're looking good
you have three kill [ __ ] no all right we
want killstreaks Raj oh nice that was
fine you did the right thing kind of
like oh the 80s there to kind of fall
okay load load load load really come on
I like Rob's patients here he's trying
to get that Koh Street okay come on baby
come on this side now I know it I can
feel it my blood oh [ __ ] okay
bring around the rosey one shot whatever
I got it I got a recon recon to kick it
off yeah okay okay that was nice little
run Dees I call that dese well dese know
where they are Rob you got eyes good
point
oh look at this jackass you knew who's
there though yeah run warble uh tanner
Hartman drop shotting I feel like is
still viable if you if you're in like a
one-on-one like done quiet I think it
still helps
but that's just me I've only played
about three or four rounds though it did
help a couple times for me personally
yeah give him that spray don't oh god
there's one to your left somewhere God I
like it though yet the right idea
alright that's it
the outer Haven production wonder if
we'll see a stalingrad return ok fire
rate high fire rate that's why I'm not a
fan of LMGs
pretty sure that was an LMG I thought
you had the double I saw you lying it up
so sure you got to just play with
aggression straight violence yes
more violence mmm
what's up loading 75 welcome welcome
alright I think this might work out
right here m1 garand that's much I am I
don't need to know how to get it for
free
I would assume you're just gonna tell me
about the Comcast ya know Molly's for
you here we go Oh any care back up
another one
oh so close dude they're all spawning
there too man oh does a dream I know
dream is dead I can't do it no dreams
not dead you know where they're at
it's kind of stuff hated them all you
got to go that looked like uh
oh no he threw a grenade I must have
heard you guys coming yeah oh [ __ ]
guy was behind me
Genki ky1 hard to say because we only
have multiplayer I mean if you enjoy cod
multiplayer it's good I think war mode
is a nice little fresh take to the cod
series not necessarily like you to like
shooters but again if you like cod
you're definitely should try this out
it's it's nice to go back like Rob said
mm-hmm from all this crazy futuristic
unpredictable
jump shots he's lagging a little bit too
are there any like explosions icon I
mean like you see the explosions nice
long head spot for that guy back damn it
not a great round rub no I know that's
all right maybe yeah the one gets a
reload this guy yup see there's a little
drop shot there up third guy shot him in
the leg keep shooting them in the butt
fine but but
triple a little triple kill all right
I'm gonna get spanked when I get home
wow that's kind of awkward you got a 12
and 10 not bad there's just that one guy
they did 23 and 7 on the other team what
you gonna do hacker man I mean your
whole team bottom half of it went like
net a huge negative you know yeah you're
my teammate
right Osama bin Penguin is this guy's
name that's pretty funny
amen
in the future crap yeah all right I get
the score let's go it's been having that
little kind of like delay absolutely in
between matches it's weird but it's made
of guys so it's expected so there you go
hey you need so honey motes guys you're
not emoting enough emote earmarked oh
his voting is to switching characters
Gilly
yo yo Kelly Sam lows sorry I don't speak
Spanish so I don't know the rest of
those words apologies but hello I'm
calling it now I'm gonna play the last
match oh I would love for you to play
last match I mean I know yeah a little
bit time okay don't forget guys we will
be streaming again tomorrow 11:00 a.m.
we're probably gonna play Cod again I
think I think it's a plan and again
thank you guys we're all tuning in we're
live every day at 11 a.m. Monday Tuesday
Thursday Friday as game SWAT live
Wednesday is the lobby
today's a little bit of an exception
yeah today was a little special second
stream because the cod beta decided to
just drop even though we were told that
it wasn't gonna be out till 10 a.m.
tomorrow which is why we were gonna
stream at 10 a.m. mm-hmm
I guess we can push that back to 11 huh
yeah now that you know cuz it doesn't it
doesn't really matter so we're probably
at 11 tomorrow
when did the Destiny to stream starts
hey asking Bob Jones next Monday we will
do enclosed PC beta at me and John Luke
and then I'm sure we'll start streaming
you know once it's out and I think we're
gonna start streaming that possibly
every Tuesday as well Bob we're gonna
make a game Spock LAN for those that are
interested in destiny even though this
is Cod so you guys should join that when
we make it cuz that's the thing now what
are we playing right now hard point hard
point are you a fan of hard point yeah I
think so right right I feel like you can
get more kills with hard point yeah do
you think this is a good Mali map Molly
Molly sobs or came back rather geez oh I
didn't I didn't select those coasters
that's alright
Oh headshots that guy needs to work he
must have like a forgot what it was
called in a black op so he could shoot
like the FAL faster and I think so
didn't start recording like those right
away there Rob but I guess it's fine got
revenge got a little bit of hipfire
accuracy going here hey back
Genki ky1 asking what are the best
weapons you've used so far I'll let Rob
dopers and then oh oh I like this ppsh
like grenades I like like the grand yeah
not by itself I like it as like a backup
for this the double barrel oh my god the
double barrel is pretty cool job yeah I
haven't haven't gone yet
good grease gun numbers I like the SMG
so far the - the grease gun and this one
I've used the type 100 a little bit just
from picking people up and that seems
pretty good too and the STS STG though
they're all the way yes yes yes TG 44
that's a class so much violence yes we
need more violence current more Rob's
not being violent enough I'm sorry he
needs to play with anger
now this is smart the smoke on the
hardpoint is smart sure is right oh we
tried to drop shot jokes on hand hope
you hide behind Oh in front - yeah yeah
get all three now when they're all
looking at me dude you just gotta you
gotta believe you gotta believe you're
gonna it's like NBA Jam you're like you
were heating up and you're like one kill
away from being on fire fair that's fair
why am I the way I am I was like Rob
please not like this alright there's a
new hardpoint decent vantage point we're
kinda getting smoked but a heart is like
it you know in a hard point you can kind
of get it back as long and controlling a
point so good am i - am i taking the
hard part yeah you guys are in the hard
point and you guys are defending it they
have to come into the hard point to get
you guys off here alright but the hard
point move now so red is definitely on
that now
giving a shake and bake and then clean
up whoo he did whoa what's going on
what's going on go jump shotting here we
go you got the hard point though that's
what matters it's not about kills
necessarily right now I mean kills do
help in terms of like looks and caring
and Kurt here's the hard point and I was
weird you're Nate hit him - I totally
buy an NBA Jam announcer oh no way she
doing typical there that's tough you
hardpoint Rob to your right oh do it do
it my friend do it to work you should
protect the see him
ah
another guy that's playing a bit you're
fine don't lose hope baby oh great Wow
some guy is slaying on the other team
yow
get another bad Dallaire alright I hear
a suppressor you hardpoints it's very
far from you guys oh is it midnight
Kezia damn not a 9 p.m. that sucks why
is it like a nap before that they're all
right you must switch weapons
that's why oh this is a very hard point
good job good job taking the hard point
all right that guy's blinded and stun
Oh fine fine you guys had this one a lot
of
all right let's change it up all right
why are you changing it up - I want to
live that shotty life that's shoddy life
not gonna happen
that's fine this will be quick okay
thank you kind of get you to play
objective based gaming right now yeah
I'm so good at hard point oh you got
someone another one Wow let me springing
tuck almost someone he's gonna house
good though you uh kind of stalled out
the hardpoint
all right got him with fire like that
come on you're burning you're out you're
on fired I'm fired okay here we go
shotgun my baby here we go swapped on
you right when you guys all got you
good
no yeah we got it Oh joke's on you buddy
that's good though I was like wow you're
the boat you guys are both but like that
guy to the second hint that's why that's
how it goes man last hit no ID but like
the first hit
Oh why he's not dead yeah that's another
story
this shotgun looks shitty yeah it
doesn't one shot and even when he was
that close I did one shot which is kind
of a double-barrel is better I think but
this one shoots faster right so you
could just say it does pop and I'm
always kind of a fan of higher fire rate
with shotguns but javis a fire started
what a terrible death are we going
regular bullets yeah yep see what I mean
like even there was an example of it
like incendiary I feel like this is just
like slower whoa because it has that
animation or something
we're gonna go where you gonna go the
top infantry is that the SDG yeah this
comes easy
we're going aar now this guy's always
cool Oh weird
I just know you guys are screaming
everyday I love it yeah I know
good plan we shall see we are alive
every day at 11:00
counting the lobby on Wednesdays from
behind they came from pit times
yeah that's right he's afraid mm-hmm
neither of those are coming back creaky
that goddamn jump I hate everyone I
guess I gotta be jumping you know just
like real water that's jumping up and
down just like what we're doing like
this Rob here we go here we go
of course I hate everyone he does hate a
lot of people mmm
I dare when I don't
look at this guy trying to leap across I
like it I like the boldness
are you guys coming back you guys are
legit coming back it is tied right whoa
come on
oh my god you see the size of that bomb
but hey it's legit tied right now oh you
guys are down two points I lied but you
guys actually have a chance you guys
were getting mo just now
okay hard point oh of course I should
have you know look yeah he did the all
the weight sitting weight the sitting
way I don't know if there's a red dot
Kippy I haven't seen it I want to see
him kind of like this there's something
there's something similar it's not
called a red dot okay clear-site or
something oh my god I can't read this
one can't wait to see how many times
I've died oh yeah Molotov oh hell yeah
we just lighten this place on fire
no you stunned them oh how many more
times
all right I'm gonna unlock the
double-barrel just to show it off okay
play another round okay
we lose a lot by line and then it's all
you okay how about a couple I think
we'll see how I do okay okay
Lucas says they had hollow sights at the
time but it was in development and
weren't used until the 1970s huh yeah
also Tanner Hartman saying they weren't
very prominent but they were in use
little juju one why do you just keep
trying to hit fire just aiming yeah I
don't know I go back and forth yeah
there's like Bates when you're that
close you might not want to always abs I
feel like no for sure I well one of the
reasons that I was hip firing was
because the the weapon I had I added a
hipfire accuracy boost so I was trying
to kind of utilize that but you know
make sense guess I better goob better be
I just better be good you just gotta get
good just got a
be a better person all I gotta do Rob
protip get good like I do this just be
super cool
you just get good and you good tacos did
anymote though they're not waving or
anything I'm all about that emo life
emote emo corporal oh I got ya Joey
you're back in Chains watch that we like
it more than the futuristic stuff as
well let's see we don't have any codes
right now at the seasick we did give
some away I think at some point but oh I
will say though tomorrow on tomorrow's
call a duty stream that we're gonna do
at 11:00 we are gonna be given some
stuff away so stay tuned to that be in
the chat and we'll kind of tell you what
to do in that regard it is called Duty
world a world war two related people
want to say world at war I don't want
this sounds cool I've no I mean Tanner
Hartman just giving us more historic
knowledge it's like all the automatic
weapons in bf1 they weren't as prominent
as they were depicted in the game but
they were still used by high-ranking
officers thank you information keep it
coming keep it coming
yeah no it's it's fair thanks for
telling us low juju I mean you if you if
you play you'll kind of feel like that
that blend of you know trying to abs
versus a hip firing a little bit
especially with an SMG of clothes so
this one fire guns while sprinting and
diving how many is that is that one
token yeah and when you talk about it do
you only get one of the basic training
so right now you have launched to look
out for word rifleman do you get all
those or is it just rifleman
it's just rifleman right that I have
yeah that I have unlocked yeah can only
pick one okay God try try this sure Oh
while sprinting actually I do like yeah
exactly I do like that it's
this sucker - boo and look you know and
then let's get out there let's let's get
out there where should we do domination
whatever you want let's get out there oh
man my choice yeah okay gah my guy looks
so cool see if anyone's playing
domination I guess you are cuz it queued
up oh so can you customize your
character look yeah a little bit once
you show that out sure
ooh faces all right mm-hmm
mm-hmm five soldiers
I would hope they're more okay car at
some emblems we haven't made a clan yet
huh either oh there you go clan tag what
do you want to be GS we get we do like
this spot like that is it only for yeah
I guess generally right I think so hey
guys hey guys does the new division
system work better than the old pic tent
what do you think mmm I haven't played
around that much with the division
system personally but I think that I
think it's interesting that each
division allows you to have kind of like
different unlocks so there is some
differentiation there so I think Callie
had mentioned that it was almost more
like Riggs but yeah unfortunately looka
I don't haven't played enough to decide
but I think anytime you just change
things up even a little bit I'd prefer
that I guess like yeah I don't know pick
ten did give you a lot of customized
like custom custom mobility customs what
is it some eyes ability I don't know
customization yeah yeah I feel like it's
needed back real quick sure the people
in your thing okay cool
yeah I guess I kind of Miss being able
to combined my own perks just like cater
to my playstyle right like but I don't
know I'm cool with it
because like the only one I really like
is just being super mobile and that's
the airborne one so it's like okay then
I'll do that and then I'll do this this
is actually what I've always always like
sprinting and firing guns that's fun I
do that in real life
yep yeah makes sense yeah totally
all right good luck to you sir thank you
so much all thank you so much I here's
the here's the other map we haven't seen
that's fine that guys wearing a napkin
on his face yeah it's like the dirt I
think I don't want to be quoted for this
but I think I was playing that class and
it's like the dirt rat something the
dirt rat mmm that's a sick rat something
costume or whatever was dirt rat costume
yeah you know what I guess I was also
afraid of like I think a lot people had
said this is like Oh God like how are
you gonna like customize your dude right
when it's it's not the future so you can
just you know hypothetically do whatever
the hell you want like pink cheetah
skins like you know you don't want to
see that in a World War 2 game like you
want to have some historical accuracy so
yeah but they're keeping the campaign
accurate sure definitely the campaign
they're not gonna mess with the players
a little but but even just there you can
kind of like mess around still you know
I didn't I guess I didn't realize that
or think about like you know you could
change up like different stuff right
you could you could you know put a
napkin on your face that's pretty good
unlock I would like that you know you
could wear it a scarf maybe you're like
me cosmetics are fine because like you
like it
it's not like the the classes or dang it
that's happened a couple times it is
beta guys so stress test it's be mindful
that kind of stuff is going to happen
what I will say is that I feel like I
keep having to like I want to be I
accidentally picked infantry is like you
know when you when you enter the beta
you pick what division you want and then
as you progress you can unlock them so
you can see like those are the those are
kind of can we call them perks
yeah these are many things you've seen
another class yeah I feel like you
slowly unlock those as you level up your
division and then you have those
abilities and there's five divisions
currently here that each have their own
kind of special perks I guess how many
maps are there right now three four like
standard multiplayer modes and then
there's the one war how's about say war
zone war map or motor mode war MO
double-barrel axe here we go
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna warm up on
this okay you're gonna dominate yeah all
right
oh wait can I customize this re I did
already here we go it's not gonna feel
weird to a little bit here and now that
you can pass sprint shoot faster guy on
the left right yeah I knew that
well your team's not really covering
from above cuz that guy should have got
use out in the open oh wait I lost yeah
I haven't played this map yet yeah this
is all the map or all the game types or
yes it is oh [ __ ]
that's like martyrdom or something or
was he just holding I think he dropped
it I haven't seen martyrdom I went
through a lot of person didn't notice it
which is good
that dumb freaking hop you know what I
mean how stiff it looks like god it's so
dumb looking oh yeah you're pinning them
in I watch me calling for this help no I
think that your team should have been
doing that while you're like totally
pushing them back let's do this
Oh making me nervous is it still a three
lane layout yeah more or less yeah more
or less
there's like you know a little bit of a
bridge - yeah are you this is call of
duty of course it'll be a three lane map
that was a prophet of reaping motion
most shooters are right
I should feel like I can't do anything
you just gotta you gotta make some big
plays Rob you gotta like I said you
gotta get violent mm-hmm you're not
being violent enough being real
nonviolent you're being a real up up oh
my god shut your mouth you need to be
new up on that old in the past album 2.0
yeah up on 2.0 who doesn't like doesn't
let people live you know like like yo up
I'm your friend oh my god you just said
I was up um that's playing like an up um
right now play like Tom Hanks okay I
take it back I like Ben Affleck Oh
Ben Affleck oh no dude no you're
thinking of I know you're thinking of
you think the VAR the you're right
though I forget that guy's name he just
reminds me of Ben Affleck he looks a lot
like Ben Affleck I think a lot of people
still think Ben Affleck was in the movie
but it wasn't Edward Burns yep yeah that
guy totally
you know not so much maybe in a helmet
in stuff accounts like take it back
sometimes in life you're wrong oh my god
look at all those fees again
that's a good little spot there all
right oh man Rob's getting serious I
keep going that way I don't like it no
you're doing I don't like it
Brandon Rosario saying it really brings
me back to that Medal of Honor feel and
the feels why don't we get these points
you jackasses
welcome to objective oh man you guys are
surprisingly not losing like that though
is surprising because they've had be for
what feels like forever what's up Jay
Garcia this would be a good secondary
yeah with that perk yeah I don't know
man after seeing that it makes me feel
like it's not a good day that guy is
crazy anyways like Ram pass his own
little voice crazy
alright cool now gun sick I'm having
such a blast you are it's gonna be
alright man this is don't Russia take us
Jay Garcia says this is painful to watch
I agree
guys its mopped it up the Holy Smoke how
is that only a bronze star against the
quad - there's your red dot or yellow
dot almost like a ACOG a little bit
don't rush take it slow
good advice domination take control it
is the beta of course all the try harder
time I think it's pretty it's pretty
melty I think it's actually pretty even
there are some people that are
definitely you don't think so I've
fought some people that like did some
real stupid stuff or it's like how did
you not kill me because like he had the
total drop on me everything
I'm about to play in a second so I could
be equally as bad for all I know thank
God thank god you're about to play okay
or I thought it was C that equally as
bad oh no Frank Sanchez come on man we
gotta we gotta bring his morale up not
down come on now
excuse me I had it I had no I didn't I
had some momentum earlier it's fine we
need we need that momentum Decker you
know how God is i dunno how God is you
go you go up and down highs and lows low
you play it like [ __ ] and then sometimes
you play like less [ __ ] I just need to
be here just a beyond a turret man
that's my role in World War 2
I'm just the mg guy yep why challenge
why bother
that's the thing right you can't play
zombies well in this mode like oh that
these maps are so small you just can't
do the same thing can't campaign about I
was a good example of not like Oh fire
what's up so Merry Christmas oh they
went all around Merry Christmas
oh I like there's one of you right don't
listen me think opposite of me
I got more molly's I'm sure do Heil oh
wow dude
sick dude I think he came around the
left smart wrapping around oh yeah you
got it you gotta give me the business
right now you shall not take this point
yep Molotov kill that works here I'm
screaming you can hear him you can hear
him he loves it oh look he loves it
terrifying
lordy who did that
I threw that Oh oh no that guy that was
camping right around like that baited
you didn't even get that guy feels bad
man oh no oh he's on the M he's on the
come on that's done didn't do yeah
there's another one right or did you get
a boat we've got to get more momentum
oh my god you got him he's bad see he's
bad you just you just gotta think in
your head everyone's bad and you're
gonna kill him alright there's one more
that's coming that way I think yeah see
BAM we are freaks
we aren't just freaks right now we got a
crate we got molotovs find a spot get it
give a care package anyway like I said
of hot now sure you got a they're not
coming to a just gotta go hide back
there dude just don't even worry about
the team don't worry about your gonna
help the team eventually here with your
care package totally
nobody spare steel it Oh get the [ __ ]
out of here Oh recon that's fine
all right we've 575 of 850 for that uh
for that artillery
oh no Baker Oh God
all right you got one you got one any
dude got one I'm surprised you didn't
die to that grenade yeah see that's what
I'm talking about right Tay Garcia there
you go you know what part of it was what
was it I didn't speak oh you went you
went full I should just shut the hell up
all right full focus baby I like it I'll
just do the talking all right here we go
yup yup yup I like it full focus get
some that's right that's right Jo golden
we gonna get something oh hello have
some fire Merry Christmas
we Steve Nash well Steve Nash it oh you
know what these guys are gonna back here
this guy's going to take a knee yeah
he's sneaking I know it feeling my blood
you're right
you were totally right you just stopped
believing in your your senses spidey
senses he's like what are you know
always inside
yup [ __ ] can't stop them can't stop
won't stop let me get it let's get Apple
back a Happy Hanukkah Apple the enemy is
taking Apple here we go
be cool of Call of Duty change your
playmaker and they're like the enemy is
taking ass oh [ __ ]
remember no more talking all right we
won cool you won't bite in it I'll play
I'll go out on that note Turk obey go
right here baby
oh let me get oh this is no good guy no
good oh yeah oh he's dead too we all I
saw the only song like your chest there
while you're getting high that's fine
that's fine okay we're gonna do a little
hot swap Turco number one nineteen
twenty not bad you got six defense
that's huge three captures well should
we what should i what mode should I play
we haven't done mosh pit what's that if
you never do that again yeah I was
kidding flip it flip it
Garcia it's almost like a oh hello
salute haha oh come on
Rob deserves to be able to emote his way
out of here I know what I was going to
say is that I feel like that's almost
like a play the game I guess we're
playing domination it loaded that was a
fast load yeah I don't know I don't know
why it went and did that but yeah you
could you could say it was inconsistent
what's up Killzone 3 10 hello are you
guys hi no I wish
hi I'm life hiya kills
oh we are tied in you're already in a
match that's why it happened so quick
oh but I thought was a guy below below
me there I've had it
I'll try that diving stuff well like
yeah you're a little late you know
everything is my fault so that's how I
look at it what do we have here we got
pistol all right we play making it
problem we're on that joint offs oh I
get it now a hip fireman hip bars good
Oh how did he kill me in one shot Rob I
got into married you know
I gots MS oh good all right I'm not I
died so many times I see jinx it
dolphin dive where you would worry a fan
of the dolphin dive were you doing a lot
of that I did it more as I started
playing more but yeah that's the way to
go especially I think that guy had an
LMG so he definitely needs to do that
there was a bomb he got two of us at
least like I stole him be like that stun
grenade oh I tried yeah yeah try to buy
time cuz I didn't have another second
there yeah I guess I got a pistol them
try to you're right by him though
did they have silenced weapons in the
beta yeah so it you the class that I
like and that we're using right now in
nine is the Airborne Division who's like
the class that has speed and stealth
more or less so at any point Eric on
smg's only air can deceiving the d-pad
in the bottom right swap to your
suppressor and take that off oh do I
have yeah only only with smg's turn that
up
let me get cvetic I'm playing terribly
right now right I'm like three and ten
yeah feels good you know it'd be cool
how is he not dead he had the same idea
it'd be cool if like if you could
combined glasses like say I wanted to be
a silent sniper with with mobility yeah
I could I could have this division class
and put a snipe like a silencer on a
sniper like why Limit this night the
sounds are too like Oh the web are not
playing with enough violence Rob violent
oh I need two three and twelve no
problem comparable to be f1 I would say
the one comparison yeah sure it's
comparable you know you got like just
looking like a more simplistic shooter
like back in the day like like both
caught and bowled I would say the most
familiar thing to battlefield is the war
mode which is reminiscent of operations
for battlefield objectives kind of that
push and pull on the map is this guy
with a shotgun I don't know what he's
doing different or what's different
about his shotgun but his [ __ ] is
hurting right here no no no not now
right here but like I've died to the
shotgun guy like a couple times was the
Oh was he
were they fire around since India in
Scenario okay no problem three and
thirteen Rob sure we're gonna clean it
up right here we're getting smoked
though I mean there is a proximity like
if you're close enough it is a one hit
kill but the range is still
yeah they have the same idea Rob I
missed without your name oh man like a
shotgun with a silencer on it so cool
[ __ ] get out of here No
should have just prone doll the way what
was I doing
all I did was Crouch yeah they haven't
covered much on the story will see
something that down the road when is
caught out again late October no Hammond
isn't it no November 3rd yeah
behind a game from behind oh that guy
earlier that's my guy you know I would
like I think hold up war had it or I'm
thinking of maybe battlefield I think
you know like hardcore mode where
they're like friendly fire that'd be fun
right wow you guys stand there for a
while shooting each other oh it's the
it's the Juke map oh he just ran I think
you just like yeah I just dipped out
[Music]
come on capture faster oh that's her
looks pretty get this guy first Oh
mm-hmm remember you got some ball toss
oh my god
your name is everywhere Nicola fly guy
here you gotta clear it out first
you won't go this way or that way oh oh
come on he's burning house he not daddy
ran to the whole thing camping in the
lodge dude how did he toss this poop
what war would you like to see these
triple a war game producers produced
next that was your buddy huh he's got a
winchester custom we should just take it
and I can fit I'd like to see that
that's so that's the last shot gun come
on I was fixing my score I fixed it kind
of you caught it I was like three and
thirteen
yeah what's that guy doing and out of
space war I think we've seen that he
said oh wait trolling they see me
trollin uh what do you wanna watch what
should I do though oh I was first on our
team that's not saying much no defense
penguin pun cake didn't do that did
alright he didn't do as bad as a the
other guy above him
14:28 yeah none of the guys died more
than 16 times and their worst guy was
still one to one so it's not good it's
how you got a look at it Rob yeah I
think you should why don't you just oh
you wanted you should do mosh pit okay
I'll try to get out that's gonna be a
letter get out um you'll get it Wesley
says I was gonna be out 10 a.m. tomorrow
and you know what
yeah bounce out bbbbb hey uh we thought
that as well but they they snot get it
snuck it they snuck it under our noses
it's out though it's out you too can
join the wall yeah join the fight I
think is what this tells you to do hit X
to join the fight
join the fight here we go we're playing
on ps4 all right what's mosh pit
rotation of the most popular multiplayer
maps now we're playing domination okay
no get out
no it's just that's what wash pit is
right a rotation of the most popular
multiplayer modes so now we're doing
hardpoint I just thought I'm a big Dumbo
no it kind of is I think no well I
thought it was like gonna like its own
but maybe it's like a mixture like while
you're playing
oh maybe no I doubt it
will there be an open beta that's a good
question I don't know maybe later on
yeah someone was saying there was but I
don't have the dates for it and when I
looked it up I didn't see it everyone's
like every post is more about this one
where's your uh you change it or you did
have your two primary ones and one yeah
you like that like that class yeah cuz
then you can you can play both ways but
we can steal a gun too I guess
absolutely I'm all about that suppressor
what does gas mask oh yeah I do we play
with violence you play with violence bye
yep yep oh okay oh yeah double it Oh
[ __ ] hang out at my house weird it's
feeling good there for a second Rob you
know felt like it was the time you know
Mike I flanked the [ __ ] out of them oh
it's back yes yeah I know I know I know
it I know that gas mask phobia is a fear
of gas masks but like putting them on I
yelled if you're wearing seeing them
just em in general are you doing there
you go
that's good that's pretty oh no did I
think your grease gun has better range
she's even here the hardpoint but we
play with violence
yeah also you're about to get it care
package good night a good night yeah you
guys are doing pretty well
oh this sounds like to get burned alive
no I wanted the triple I ran out of
bullets robbed damn dude and I got
excited you were a Killa where I think
my care package Thanks
[Music]
oh he's on the turret oh [ __ ] yep kill
that guy you just climbed out of the
frickin thing just gotta go for the gold
you're not gonna see Nazi scientists jet
pack DLC oh no I went past him and I was
oh I was out of bullet and then the
hardpoint cool yeah at least I got my
stun grenade off frickin did something
that's fun you just go hand these guys
are doing a great job of like holding
the point I'm just trying to like make
some big plays yep take some camping
plays now that oh that was a good stun
grenade yeah it was good
you had the right idea
oh god what's not look at that guy's
playing point playing smart playing up
him people on their team correct
there's four the game does sound good
yeah somebody made that comment earlier
as well no idea where these guys are
where are they coming from I just see my
team good stuff good stuff yeah look at
that look at that they Redemption oh
that one guy did pretty good contain his
team again smash look all that time he
got on the hardpoint I was keeping them
back you all don't let her totally
taking care of biz oh god this guy got
those Wow
and died right away good stuff so d okay
so if this is to get some wash [ __ ]
cycles then right is that what it is I
believe so yeah thanks sounds g-spot
yeah oh yeah
well what do you want to do I don't know
you tell me um we can probably call it
here we're gonna play again tomorrow
yeah let's take a little breather yeah
all right that was cool that's so that's
a Call of Duty World War 2 private beta
cool game new game you just go to camera
why not we yeah just oh well obviously
the names anyway that's fine
yeah when she send us out of here we
will be leaving we're sending it we're
sending it out of here
man this room just get a little stuffy
and you can see myself come out look
listen
little little nice glaze well thanks
Eric thank you rob
thank you and thank all y'all for
watching and hanging out we will be
streaming again again tomorrow at 11
a.m.
no we're gonna do 10 a.m. tomorrow but
no need we'll be at a 11:00 streaming
again some Cod do join us hopefully
we'll have some progress as far as you
know some perk trees unlocked maybe a
couple new weapons to look at yep and
yeah definitely thanks for watching and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe if you
guys want to see more stuff oh wha later
[Music]